et katia bonjour alors quelles sont les
dernières informations sur la santé du
président l'écouté est mon hamac ou
présenter des symptômes légers
il a fait un test pcr qui est revenu
positif aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'écouter le communiqué de presse de
l'elysée à son sujet le président de la
république a été diagnostiqué positif à
la coved 19 ce jour ce diagnostic a été
établi suite à un test
rt pcr réalisé dès l'apparition des
premiers symptômes
conformément aux consignes sanitaires en
vigueur applicables à tous
le président de la république s'isolera
pendant sept jours
il continuera de travailler et d'assurer
ses activités à distance donc mis à
l'isolément emmanuel macron continuera à
travailler mais il devra évidemment
annulé ce déplacement donc son voyage au
liban la semaine prochaine sera annulé
quant à jean castex le premier ministre
ils ne présentent pas de symptômes pour
le moment il sera testé fait sert d'eux
lui il devra annuler la présentation de
sa stratégie vaccinale au sénat c'est
olivier verront ministre de la santé qui
va s'en charger donc il est mis à l'
isolement à l'isolément également
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale a jugé qu'à
contacter alors parlons un peu des
occasions de contamination mardi midi
les neuf présidents des groupes
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
ont été reçus à déjeuner à l'elysée
christophe castaner le patron et les
roms à l'assemblée damien bat pour les
républicains valérie rabault pour le ps
jean luc mélenchon pour la france
insoumise pour ne citer qu'eux mais ne
sont pas considérés comme cas contacts
car il aurait respecté les mesures
barrières les gestes qu'il convient de
déployer dans ce cas autre événement qui
fait jaser en revanche la fête hier soir
qui a été donné dans la salle des fêtes
de l'elysée selon une information du
point alors il aurait rassemblé des
dirigeants de la majorité des directeurs
de cabinet étaient présents le premier
ministre jean castex
il y avait richard ferrand christophe
castaner françois bayroux encore patrick
mignola le président du modem
alors pour les participants interrogé
par le point les règles de distanciation
sociales ont été respectées les gestes
barrière également mais disons que ce
type de rassemblement une dizaine de
personnes qui s'est terminée vers minuit
et demi donc qui n'a pas vraiment
respecté les consignes les consignes de
nombres qui ont été données par le
gouvernement est bien ne montre pas
vraiment l'exemple
si beaucoup avoue qu'être a peiné pour
toutes ces précisions vous